what we're seeing in coming out of
shanghaied them out to some extent there
are some noise there and we're having to
assume that the government is making the
right course it's always interesting in
these situations because you can react
to one of two ways you can say gosh
they've done something about a weakening
economy is that bad or good well if they
recognized it right and the measures
start to impact the economy positively
then it's actually grounds for optimism
I think they may need to do some more
tinkering and make some changes
certainly with what's going on in the
property sector we had some data showing
you the highest prices have picked up in
China that's interesting when you
consider the big stock market slip we
had in June so kind of illustrates that
perhaps the the danette effect on wealth
on consumer confidence in China was much
less than people anticipated and but of
course we will lead to see a more
durable run in house prices before
calling turning the housing sector and
of course from there for attorney
calling a turn in the economy have we
got a base being formed for the real
estate market in China as a whole I
would say it's early days i think the
positive comment is probably further
major downside in chinese real estate
prices is probably quite limited now
there is some speculation today which is
why the shanghai composite has fallen
with it with better real estate data
that takes away an excuse for the PBOC
to ease further and i would completely
disagree with that i gather the PBOC are
not just looking at the real estate
market they're looking at the broader
economy
china's health is an issue for everyone
and i think in the the longer term you
have this deflationary impulsive they
continue to devalue which is going to
affect all policy william monetary
policy around the world like I think
that this is this is just making this a
knife-edge season it even more difficult
about whether to go in September or not
yeah I don't envy the policymakers
decision but on enough is it is it
enough alone to just stop them No